>> TURNS OUT CANCEL CULTURE HAS
ANOTHER CASUALTY IN THIS TIME
IT'S YOU.
A NEW STUDY FINDS AMERICANS ARE
CENSORING THEMSELVES ON HOW THEY
REALLY FEEL ABOUT HOT BUTTON
ISSUES.
CEOs GOING WOKE ON SOCIAL
ISSUES, SCHOOLS FOCUSING ON
RACISM, MASKS STOP THINK OF A
COVERED, PEOPLE PUBLICLY SAY
THEY AGREE WITH EACH OF THOSE
SEEMINGLY POPULAR STANCES BUT
PRIVATELY THEY ARE NOT SO SURE.
IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE OUT THERE IN
THE WORLD AND WE'VE GOT THE SELF
CENSOR.
>> SELF-CENSORSHIP IS PART OF
LIFE, IF YOU SAID EVERYTHING YOU
THOUGHT YOU WOULD BE ME.
I'M PLEASANT TO THE PEOPLE
AROUND ME IS GETTING IN TROUBLE,
BUT THAT'S TEAM TO PULL.
HAVING MANNERS.
NOT CALLING OUT PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE AND
CANCEL CULTURE IS ABOUT CALLING
OUT PEOPLE AND BEING IMMUNE FROM
ANY KIND OF DISCUSSION
AFTERWARD.
LIKE I'M THE VICTIM, YOU'RE THE
OPPRESSOR, AND THEY CAN SHUT UP
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
IT'S KIND OF DANGEROUS WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
IN A CONVERSATION, WHAT'S LEFT?
YOU CAN HAVE VIOLENCE AND SAY
THIS PERSON IS EXPRESSING
INFLAMMATORY LANGUAGE.
THAT SHOULDN'T WORRY YOU AT ALL,
WHAT SHOULD WORRY YOU IS IF WE
STOP TALKING BECAUSE IF WE STOP
TALKING IT MEANS WE WILL DO
SOMETHING REALLY BAD BECAUSE
WE'LL GO BACK TO OUR UNDERGROUND
CAVE AND PLAN THINGS.
THE SOLUTION TO DEFY SELF
CANCELLATION IF YOU'RE YOUNG IS
TO GET SO GOOD AT SOMETHING THAT
YOU CAN LEAVE.
IF YOUR COMPANY GET SUPER WOKE,
YOU CAN LEAVE AND IT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW WHEN YOU SEE THE WOKE
WORKERS AT DISNEY, GOOGLE,
PUBLISHING, GENERALLY THE LEAST
COMPETENT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
LEAVE THE COMPANY SO YOU GET THE
88 COLONEL, THE CENTER OF
DUMBNESS IN EVERY COMPANY AND
ITS ALL THE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
LEAVE.
IF >> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
YOU DON'T SELF CENSOR VERY MUCH.
>> I'M SURE YOU HEARD FROM
PEOPLE COMING UP SAYING I LOVE
THE SHOW AND LOVE LISTENING TO
YOU BECAUSE --
YOU KNOW, I'M JUST A STRAIGHT
SHOOTER AND THAT'S WHO I AM.
FROM WHENCE I COME I WAS A WOMAN
IN A MAN'S WORLD.
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING?
TODAY IN SCHOOL, THEY ARE NOT
TEACHING OUR KIDS TO THINK.
THEY ARE TEACHING AND IDEOLOGY
AND THEY ARE TEACHING THIS GROUP
THINK.
WE ALL THINK THIS AND THIS IS
WHAT YOU MUST THINK.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE RAISING A WHOLE
GENERATION OF YOUNG KIDS WERE
THOUGHT TO THINK THE SAME WAY
THEIR PEERS THINK.
WHILE WE THINK INDEPENDENTLY AND
BE THAT BRIGHT PERSON WHO CAN
BREAK FROM THE MOB, I'M NOT SURE
WHO THE KIDS THAT ARE COMING UP
NOW WILL BE ABLE TO BE THAT
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BEEN TAUGHT HOW TO THINK.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY
THINGS.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK WHEN YOU
PICKED UP THE ARTICLE?
>> I WAS THINKING ABOUT
VACCINATION FOR KIDS.
WE ALL GENERALLY ACCEPTED THAT
VACCINE BECAUSE YOU CAN GET
COVID.
BUT NOW YOU'VE GOT VACCINES
AVAILABLE FOR KIDS SIX MONTHS T.
IF THEY ARE NOT VACCINATING
THEIR KIDS AND THEY WERE HAPPY
TO TAKE THE VACCINE THEMSELVES
BUT THEY'RE NOT COMFORTABLE
DOING IT IF THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
INFORMATION OR IF THE KIDS NEED
IT BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
BE THAT DISRUPTIVE.
KIDS HAVE PASSED AWAY AND ALL
THE LADS COME UP WITH THE MOST
INTERESTING PART OF THIS BECAUSE
I HAVE A TON OF LIBERAL FRIENDS.
IT WAS THEIR TURN TO GET
VACCINATED AND THERE WAS A
CONCERN ABOUT WHY IT'S NECESSARY
OR WHAT HAPPENED IN THE STUDY
OUT OF THAILAND ABOUT TEENAGE
BOYS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE DIDN'T DO
THE STUDY IN THE U.S.
SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY BIG DEAL,
THE SECOND DOSE OF THE PFIZER
VACCINE WAS LEADING TO A BIG
UPTICK IN CASES.
>> DO YOU THINK MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE GUILTY OR PRACTICE
THIS LIKE SELF-CENSORSHIP?
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE ARE SAYING
THIS AND THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO
SAY SOMETHING ELSE?
>> LESS THAN THE AVERAGE PUBLIC
BUT IT'S A ONE-WAY STREET, THE
RIGHT DOES VERY LITTLE ABOUT
CENSORING LIBERALS.
>> QUIET, JESSICA.
>> YOU'VE GOT MAJORITY --
>> THAT'S A BIG LIE.
>> WHEN YOU'RE AFRAID OF LOSING
YOUR JOBS OR BEING SHAMED
SOCIALLY OR BEING A STUDENT, YOU
WILL CURTAIL YOUR BELIEF.
YOU NEED TO SHUT UP THE
CONVERSATION, CANCEL PEOPLE,
SHAME PEOPLE ON TWITTER.
YOU CAN'T LET PEOPLE DEBATE THE
THINGS BECAUSE IF THEY DO,
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL GO THIS IS
HORRIBLE!
I DON'T WANT TO BE TRANSITIONING
12-YEAR-OLD KIDS!
I DON'T WANT TO BE GIVEN MY
8-YEAR-OLD CHILD A VACCINE!
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF THINGS
YOU SHOULD DEBATE BUT YOU WON'T
AND THEY SILENCE US BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW --
>> TO BE FAIR, TO DEFEND YOU IN
THE SENSE THAT WE WERE LIKE
THAT.
THIS HAS BEEN A HUGE SWITCH.
IT USED TO BE THE REPUBLICANS,
REMEMBER, THEY WERE PURITANICAL,
PRETTY CLOSE-MINDED ON A LOT OF
THINGS.
THEN YOU SEE A FLIP.
THE LEFT HAS TO BE ABOUT SPEECH
AND NOW IT'S FLIPPED.
NOW WE ARE ALL ABOUT SPEECH.
>> SILENCE HAD FREE REIGN.
>> THERE WAS A BOOK BAND THAT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
REPUBLICANS, THE LEFT NOW THE
ONES.
>> IT G